In this section, we'll learn about
aggregating or summarizing data.
For example, you might want to summarize
transactional data that list each
product sold within one
transaction as separate records.
So if you wanted to calculate
the total sale of a transaction,
you'd need to sum up the products
within each transaction.
Or maybe you want to count
the number of tweets associated
with a store location
in a particular month.
Then you'd need to count these
up within that time frame.
If we think back to the example
mentioned at the beginning of
the lesson,
we have daily sales data, and
we want to build a forecasting
model to forecast monthly sales.
Then the data going into the model is
going to need to be aggregated, so
that each record represents
a monthly value.
If you were going to summarize
this data by month in Excel,
you'd need to create a pivot
table from the daily sales data.